all right i want to wrap up with the
question we ask everyone we need a
bitcoin price prediction by end of year
and i need an ethereum price prediction
by end of year what do you got for us
uh i was doing some work on this on the
weekend for global macro investor i'm
kind of thinking
i'm kind of a little bit overly bullish
right now
and i think the cycle well no because
that's not fair because i was looking at
the cycle itself i think bitcoin
somewhere north of
200 and eth closer to
15k
but i think we finished the cycle with
bitcoin close to 400 and each closer to
40 000.
all right so you think by end of year
we've got bitcoin 200k or so we've got
ethe at 15k you think end of cycle which
in your opinion sounds like kind of
february march of next year something
like that yeah bitcoins 400 000 and
eighth is forty thousand
yeah
i uh there's a lot of people watching
who hope you're right
i bloody hope so too you know it's not
like i haven't backed my own bet so
my money's where my mouth is i hear you
all right tell us a little bit uh about
real vision and where can we send people
if they want to check out real vision
all the great content you guys are doing
there yeah look the easiest thing is if
you're interested in crypto we've got a
entire channel we built for it called
real vision crypto um it's free all you
need is pop your email address and it's
wall-to-wall content every friday um i
i've got my own show which is called
rails adventures in in crypto and there
i'm interviewing the most interesting
people i can find to get my knowledge up
so you can follow me on that journey so
realvisioncrypto.com or realvision.com
forward slash crypto it's free i urge
you to sign up it's there for you it's a
resource that we built for everybody
because this is the most exciting
dynamic space i've ever seen so that's
the that's that's the best way and you
can always find me on twitter at raul um
r-a-o-u-l-g-m-i
you uh you got some of the best uh the
best threads i love when i think that
you're just sitting there you're like no
what i got something to say you just go
on one of these uh you just rip off a
thread and i'm like man that is just a
stream of thoughts that people needed to
hear that's pretty damn good
yeah just trying to think this all
through you know because none of us know
the answers so to think it through put
it out there get it tested it's good
i love it the uh as you can imagine the
comments love four hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin and 40k eth you're uh
you're gaining fans by the second so
[Laughter]
awesome listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this i highly
suggest anybody
who's watching this go check out uh real
vision crypto or follow role on twitter
and we will have to do this again my
friend
always and we'll get you on on our side
of the fence soon as well all right
sounds good talk soon
all right take care of them all right
thank you
john i'm coming right to you what do you
think
dropping bombs
yeah that was a big bomb drop 400k by
the end of the cycle and what i actually
really enjoy about talking about is um
he's got to understand the macro uh
kind of investing landscape and
he's been able to identify a number of
different things that are pretty
interesting everything from kind of the
repeat of the network effect and how
that overlays with price but also being
able to understand uh those risk curves
and how people just naturally are moving
between the risk curves again he's more
of in my opinion a mercenary right he's
looking more for
right now how can i allocate capital for
the highest potential outcome on a
risk-reward basis whereas some people
are more missionaries they're looking
for uh hey i believe in this
technology's impact on the future and
i'm going to allocate my capital based
on the world i want to see not
necessarily on trying to optimize for
the highest potential economic return
right neither one's right or wrong it's
just there are two different ways to
kind of look at the world
and naturally what do you get a lot of
traders a lot of kind of wall street
investors who are used to being very
tactical moving positions on a
continuous basis they tend to be more
mercenary because they say look i i uh
am uh not a kind of beholden to any
religion right when it comes to an asset
any narrative i'm willing to change my
mind rapidly if the facts or information
changes as well